climate change is affecting the --use
water resources water shortages and
droughts are becoming more and more
frequent water scarcity affects at least
eleven percent of the European
population and 17 percent of EU
territory the EU wants to ensure that
his water sources are protected for the
future by reusing water as much as
possible no [ __ ] amore utilities are a
cinema saver goalless Emily Rd Dmitriy
QbD aqua 10 llamo president a Georgian
until diamo solo movie : emilio de
diametrically wind abbiamo UN
potentially normal our internal saying
para llamar new movie featuring the de
la resource America it's all part of the
circular economy reduce reuse and
recycle and it's just the same with
water Parliament is backing plans to
reclaim urban waste water for irrigation
in farming MEP s want to promote the use
of treated water to irrigate both food
and non-food crops la puesta de utilidad
I'm principal modo / a loser Agricola
monkey rusev severely EU countries
should also be able to reuse water for
industrial or environmental purposes as
long as it doesn't harm people or the
environment
[Music]